i cross my fingers cross your fingers
but it does seem like something is
happening
although it's it's sort of slow
redirecting the live streaming page
not now it's going to ask me if i want
to
take advantage of all the services that
zoom can
can offer all right we are going
live in one minute there there's 21
people
already online they're already wondering
why am i
why am i nerding out with a lawyer you
know that uh speaking of hubble
uh larry did you know that allegedly
hubble said uh his father wanted him to
become a lawyer
and he's he said i'd rather be a
second-rate astronomer than a first-rate
lawyer
well you know i share that view in a
in a future life i would rather be even
a third-rate
astronomer and cosmologist than a
first-rate lawyer i mean you guys are
tuned into the universe to the ultimate
truth of things that's uh
i can't compare to that well you do an
awesome job at it larry i'm talking to
lawrence tribe the carlow professor
and professor university professor and
professor of constitutional law
at harvard was taught at its law school
since 1968 the year before we landed on
the moon
maybe we'll get to that he was voted
best professor by the graduating class
of 2000 the title of university
professors harvard's highest academic
honor awarded to just a handful of
professors
at any given time and just 68 professors
in all of harvard university's history
um why are you slumbering it with an
astrophysicist here larry
why am i what are you why are you
slumming it with an astrophysicist
on the contrary i feel really honored to
be in your presence
you're in touch with things i can barely
imagine
well we got in uh connected together
through a mutual friend
avi loeb who i i don't think is uh
related to uh carl loeb
uh but uh but avi is a good friend and
he is an astronomer and he is feeling a
lot of heat
and uh and for for the light that he has
illuminated
about certain uh astrophysical entities
but what i wanted to talk to you today
about
was uh kind of something that's in the
news you may have heard of it uh it's
called the impeachment
of donald trump and in preparation for
this i said
uh i i assumed i'm sorry to say i knew
you were a math you know had a
significant math background
i assumed you were a nerd and i said i
want to nerd out
about the geometry of the constitution
because many people
uh uh may not be aware that uh euclid
in particular and great mathematicians
had a tremendous influence
not only on abraham lincoln that's
that's sort of been
been discussed before but but also on
thomas jefferson
in the writing of the declaration of
independence he says we hold these
truths to be self-evident
that's directly pulled from euclid is it
not it certainly is and
the idea of self-evident truth and of
having to begin
with a set of axioms or postulates that
themselves can't be proved is obviously
central to the
mathematical enterprise and to the
enterprise of mathematical logic which
was
one of the things i was most grooving on
when i was
before i became started slumming as a
lawyer as it were
and uh we went back and forth and i want
to definitely get your
impression about about the kind of
influence of
legal think on legal thinking of the
great minds of mathematicians
and and also maybe um uh go into
some detail on the influence it had on
on lincoln because he he sort of
modified some of the
propositions etc as you know um but it
will be interesting to compare those
two different phrasings of things that
were held to be self-evident and
reminded of that of that quote you know
sometimes we the things we think of as
self-evident
ain't necessarily so and so i asked you
for some you know
some tips or some papers i could read
you know that would be
that would be simple enough for a humble
astrophysicist and you pointed me to
eight papers totaling 273 pages
and i only had a day to read it and i
just want to thank you so much larry for
confirming
my bias that i was never cut out for law
school this is like an easy day for your
law students right 273 pages in a night
not really i i took advantage of the
fact that you
seemed to be a really brilliant fast
reader and you said
you know i have a little time before
lunch can you send me some papers and i
thought oh well
if brian is going to be ambitious no
reason to hold back so i
i pulled together a few things and one
of those we'll talk about in just a
minute uh it's called the curvature of
constitutional space
and this uh is in the harvard law review
a
little-known uh you know uh the journal
that that some of us subscribe to on a
weekly basis
but for those of us who don't i'll put
some information in the show notes
uh this article that i absolutely
devoured and now i can say
you know larry once i was visiting my
brother he went to berkeley college of
music
and i visited him during the boston
marathon and
there was a point where i had across
what is it boylestown or
commonwealth avenue you know so much
better than i'm sure you've run it many
times
and i had to cross the street and i i
made sure to run across the street so i
could say i ran in
the boston marathon um so now i can say
i've read i mean it sounds like you
would make a good lawyer
well our our people are not exactly
known for not
having having arguments i can't say if i
have good arguments but um
but i uh but one thing i asked you brian
did you notice
footnote one of that paper it
acknowledges the help of my research
assistant
at the time maybe you skipped that it
was
barack obama yes i was going to get to
that
one so right i was going to say that
i've read something that has been
read not only by a well-known
constitutional
uh uh law professor but also someone who
held the the highest law in
office in the land who may still be
still
i don't know if is he subject to
impeachment because larry the thing i am
so
interested in is there you know we and
you wax
very rhapsodically about this the goal
of
of science in some sense in physics at
least is to come up with a theory
of everything it's it's a shorthand for
for an all-encompassing thing
i want to ask you right is the
constitution a theory of
everything or is it a theory of anything
is it relative in the sense that the
normal person says oh it's all relative
or is it relative in the way that i
and my colleagues as physicists talk
about relativity
what does it mean in what sense is it a
theory of everything or anything
well it's certainly not a theory of
everything because it's
contingent on in a number of
circumstances it was cobbled together
as a compromise among very dis disparate
vectors really
pointing in very different directions
some towards slavery some toward human
emancipation some toward equality some
toward subordination
so it is certainly not all-encompassing
there are alternative universes in which
different constitutions might
achieve somewhat similar aims in terms
of
justice in terms of tranquility
in terms of the benefits of liberty
and of equality and it has internal
tensions that have never been fully
resolved it has
pieces that don't make sense in terms of
others the electoral college is
incompatible with the principle of one
person one vote
even though slavery has been erased it
hasn't fully been erased because there's
an exception written into the
anti-slavery amendment
for people who are forced to work as
part of a penal sentence
so it is certainly not a theory of
everything
but seeking coherence seeking to treat
it as a coherent whole
reconciling its tensions is at least for
me one of the
central and most exciting aspects of the
constitutional enterprise
that is if people want to read it in a
certain way one of the arguments is
well that's not what they meant when
they wrote it but since the people who
wrote it were wise enough to know
that they were projecting something into
a
distant future it's clear that what they
originally meant was not wholly
determinate and
might not be binding so then you look at
what would make the best sense of it but
best in
terms of what then you have a kind of
meta constitution that is
what are the principles to which the
constitution should conform
it's an endless enterprise and a little
bit like girdle's theorem there's really
no way
within the context of the finite
constitution
even to decide what is actually a part
of it because for example when an
amendment
is proposed in 1789
and not ultimately ratified until 1990
or so and that happened with one
amendment
there are conflicting views as to
whether it's really part of the
constitution i once had an argument with
justice scalia
about that in an elevator at princeton
and we had
very different views and when i was
trying to explain the constitution to a
group of fifth graders it turned out
they were more
interested and excited in the
though i didn't use this language in the
indeterminacy of the question of what's
really part of the constitution
and the problem of infinite
self-reference of trying to
have a rule about what are the rules and
then a rule about how to read the rules
even fifth graders can get turned on by
puzzles
of that kind and when those puzzles are
also relevant to human life and death
and to the question of whether we're
going to have a tyrant in charge of all
of our lives
or govern our lives and that's what's at
stake in the current impeachment trial
then you know that even though it's not
cosmology
it's not it's not just spinach either
it's funny you reference girdle i was
going to get to the fact that uh they're
one of the greatest logicians of all
time
and good friends with a little known
patent clerk former patent clerk by the
name of albert einstein
he was becoming a citizen in the late
1940s and he consulted with his friend
albert
and he said um hey albert i i seem to
have discovered a contradiction in the
constitution
uh maybe you want to say something about
that and what albert's
advice to him was well his advice was
don't let them know that they might not
appreciate that when you seek your
papers but by the way it's a book by jim
holt
um do you know the book
if you flip through it he called me once
holt did
and said you know i i really wondered
whether
a constitutional theorist who was also a
logician
would have anything to say about the the
fallacy that girdle thought he found in
the constitution the fallacy was
that the constitution within its own
framework could could permit its own
self-destruction
and because it would permit its own
self-destruction
it was really incoherent and not worthy
and my answer to that is any
finite system designed to project
human aspirations into the future has
bound to have internal contradictions of
a sort that would
permit the destruction of the
constitution so
you really haven't discovered any unique
contradiction in the constitution anyway
i was pleased to see
that that discussion with holt appear in
a
discussion of the conversation that girl
had with einstein i felt like it was a
very special company yes yeah that
uh that that description of course
girdle is famous for the incompleteness
theorem
and i claim larry this is a topic for
another day we're talking with larry
tribe
lawrence tribe uh the low professor of
law
and the harvard uh university professor
uh we're talking about
uh not only all things political all
things constitutional
but uh but also about the applications
and the
and the potentiality of physical law of
scientific law
to influence the laws of human beings i
think aristotle said
something to the effect that you know
humans are animus uh politicus in other
words we are by nature political
and i found it very interesting reading
reading through this wonderful
um essay in harvard law review from 1989
called the curvature of constitutional
space
what lawyers can learn from modern
physics uh in is that
um we are animated in some sense to
always maybe seek conflict over things
which are
in indeterminate perhaps to say you know
relativity again i
as a physicist i hate oh it's all
relative you know that's that's like a
sure way to
to to start you know to get me to get me
frustrated and
bile but but uh we both talk about
things in in
in our respective fields about states
about the positions and it seems to me
that some of the most controversial
things we have
are not amenable to our classical brains
our brains evolved to see
tigers to see threats of snakes and is
it a snake and we were kind of
negativity biased
we're not quantum beings we we we are
superpositions of
of quantum objects um and and even
though i've had deepak chopra on
recently i'm not going to get too
woo-woo on you uh but but the point is
that
the most frustrating things in in
as classical beings trying to understand
the quantum world
are superpositions so the famous and and
you make oblique reference to this in
this paper but you talk about heisenberg
but of course the most famous one is
schrodinger's cat and
and this indeterminate state and it just
drives our classical brains wild
because we can't comprehend of some
superposition
and i wonder is that some of the
frustration that we see
in the law reading reading through this
paper and you know it could have been
written in in you know 2019
2021 because you talk about abortion
now good thing we solved that good thing
that's no longer controversial
and i was thinking like abortion one of
my friends uh harvard alum eric
weinstein talks about
you know the frustration of abort like
nobody thinks a fetus
is a anything to do a living organism
before the parents meet each other and
have their big bang as
as fred hoyle used to say right and
nobody would say that it's not a baby
you know like
my toddlers are not babies right so so
it's that superposition
is it a baby you know when is it a baby
what talk about the in
the fundamental indeterminacy that you
cannot collapse a wave function
in juris prudence space the way we i
can't i have an easy job
you know i can make an observation but
talk about what
the struggle is as you know trying to
come to a decision
in in jurisprudence when these things
aren't well determined
well you know i had a long conversation
years ago
with i guess a colleague of yours murray
gelman
and we we co-edited a book
called when values conflict and there
were a series of essays in there but it
was really the ultimate idea
of sort of not being able to come up
with an
algorithm for resolving fundamentally
conflicting values i
i was intrigued not only at a human
level but at a
metaphysical level about the problem of
abortion because
i wrote another little book called um
i guess the clash of absolutes and it
was about the fact that you have
both from one point of view one view of
the universe
even though what we have inside of
women's uterus is obviously
not a doctor or lawyer or a physicist
but is also not just protoplasm and
depending on
how you think about time and future
selves
there's a lot more there than just a
bunch of molecules
on the other hand people who emphasize
that collectivity and say it has certain
rights
or in some instances treating the woman
who carries it as a kind of
you know involuntary uterus i mean is is
it
right is it wrong to compel
someone to make a decision about her
future her life um
in a way that she wouldn't choose to do
i mean how do you
resolve that clash of absolutes it's
really very similar i think to
collapsing a wave function
and i don't think there is any kind of
universally acceptable
elixir that will dissolve it but i'm
actually fascinated by
your point about how our brains may not
be built
to resolve certain kinds of conflicts
indeed they may not be built to
comprehend certain things i mean we
we are you know biological beings where
protoplasm
something that the artificial
intelligence people sometimes
conveniently set aside
assuming that that we are only a set of
of zeros and ones and a set of
and some software um
but it may be that the way we are
constructed simply
doesn't pick up certain signals about
the universe about intelligence that's
why i find
of a loeb's concept that
that we really ought not to dismiss too
easily the possibility of
extraterrestrial intelligence having
already visited
visited us we ought not to dismiss it
simply because it sounds
zany um anyway i i'm
i'm digressing i'm not sure i'm
responding no no
it is and anyway we haven't talked about
impeachment yet which i hope we get to
because yeah i want to get to that in
just one second
but i i did want to bring up artificial
intelligence you i
i had a conversation with your crosstown
rival nom chomsky about it last summer
and you know this he's kind of a strong
touring yes where he believes that it's
meaningless to talk about certain things
and you know can machines think but i i
i'd love to talk maybe some other time
about artificial intelligence in the
concept of like can you abort an
artificial intelligence a beyond
as a fellow uh mit professor am uh max
tag mark says
it becomes life 3.0 based on the moore's
law extrapolation of current technology
not even saying things like like the
singularity or alien civilizations just
that it will have a capability
can it feel pain what are the moral
obligations can you agree
and i think i mean that's why i'm so
fascinated about animal rights
about which i've written a great deal i
mean what is it that makes something a
rights bearing
entity is it simply its resemblance to
ourselves is its capacity to have
to perceive moral obligation capacity to
to feel pain i don't think you know the
constitution
intriguingly doesn't necessarily
give us any guidance in answering that
question it uses as a kind of blank
variable
the term person but that doesn't ever
explain what a person
is and beyond that
constitution actually contains a series
of prohibitions that are not dependent
on our notion of who or what has rights
like for example
uh slavery shall not exist in the united
states that's what the 13th amendment
says
doesn't say anything about persons
that's why i've represented elephants
and
and chimpanzees and dolphins in various
cases saying they shouldn't be enslaved
it also says there shall be no cruel
unusual punishments
it's kind of a negative it doesn't say
no person shall be subjected to a cruel
unusual punishment that's why i think
it's right that we have laws against
uh against mistreating little animals
but
again i i digress yeah so i do want to
turn to
impeachment i want to phrase it in a uh
physics context so
we have laws that that underpin our
understanding of nature
uh but also characterize their ignorance
of nature uh but one thing you know
is is for certain when we when we are
talking about definitive observations or
past events or retrodictions
there are limitations and the
limitations in the constitution
seem i mean the constitution you correct
me if i'm wrong uh
mentions impeachment no no fewer than
six times
and nowhere does it say you can impeach
a president or can
but but it seems clear to me at least
maybe you'll disagree with me
but at least within the curvature of
space-time and the constitutional limits
in space
it doesn't seem like you could impeach
me brian keating you know a professor of
physics for
you know for some high crimes
misdemeanors whatever but um
in other words i'm not in that position
in space
but um but you're claiming if i'm not
mistaken that you could that the
bounds of time do not do not apply as
well so can you talk about
the confirmationality of it right well
here we have a lot of guidance from the
actual architecture and text of the
constitution
although it mentions it six times there
are only two important places where it's
mentioned
the place where it's mentioned in a
context that leads some people to make
what i think is the fallacious argument
that it's not permissible to
conduct and conclude a trial of donald
j trump because he's no longer president
that is in article 2 section 4 which
says that the president
vice president and other civil officers
of the united states
shall be impeached
upon
having committed i don't have the
language in front of me uh
trees and bribery or other high crimes
and misdemeanors
that's kind of a limitation it sort of
says there are certain things
that civil officers cannot do without
being impeached and convicted and
removed
but it doesn't say that removal is the
only thing that can happen
if that were the case then clearly it
would make no sense to impeach someone
who is non-removable because they've
already
uh moved to a different space they're no
longer an officer
the key point however is that article
one
which is the place where the senate gets
its sole power to try impeachments and
where the house gets the sole power to
impeach which is like indicting
article 1 does not contain any
limitation that says
you must be an officer in order to be
impeached
indeed when the thing was written
the key example that the framers of our
constitution had in front of them
was the example of the parliament of
england impeaching
a guy who had since resigned
as the governor general of
bengal he was impeached
in the sense that you can put a scarlet
letter on someone he was impeached he
was charged with crime
long after he was gone however
that problem can you impeach someone who
is no longer
a public officer doesn't really arise in
the case of donald trump
because he was president when he was
impeached the only question really is
having impeached someone are you
unable then to carry the impeachment
forward
to the point of a conviction
just because the person has run off the
clock or committed the most heinous
crimes
near the very end of his or her term in
office
and there i think the answer is quite
clear the senate's sole power
to try all impeachments contains no
exception
for someone who has managed to
get out from under the wire just in time
and the key
is that the framers of the constitution
knowing that
you would not want to convict someone
of high crimes and misdemeanors unless
they were
in deep danger to the republic
they provided not only for removal but
for permanent
disqualification that is when someone
has shown himself to be a tyrant
rather than a democrat with a small d
you don't just want to get rid of him
you want to make sure that he doesn't
return with the private army that he's
managed to assemble the way this guy did
in taking over the capital though by
remote control
and the power to disqualify
someone is central to the impeachment
power that's sort of the way lawyers
argue they look at the language they
look
at the history they look at the
precedent they look at the purpose
not everybody agrees but the
overwhelming majority of lawyers think
that this impeachment is perfectly
legitimate but
because it's a political process and
because a lot of the people
who are afraid still of trump's database
and of his command over
a loyal rather violent army
a lot of them look for cover and easy
cover might be to say oh well we don't
have power to
render any decision at all they were
outvoted on that 56-44 but they're still
going to
persist in arguing just as they're going
to argue that since he used words
in order to inflict massive injury on
the capitol
he's somehow protected by the freedom of
speech quite a canard and
not really a meaningful use of the free
speech context
but we don't know you know a lot of
people say what's the point of it all
it looks like the votes are not there to
convict him it takes two-thirds of the
senders who are voting
that's quite premature i mean one of the
main dynamics of any trial including an
impeachment trial is people start to
come forward
with information that they have and
there are probably lots of people
out there who know exactly what trump
was doing
during the riot which is one of the
questions here i mean was he really
watching the riot and cheering the
rioters on
or was he distractedly watching some
daytime tv show
uh and therefore being derelict in his
duty but not
really inciting the rioters that's a
question
there may be more evidence about that
yeah yeah and
i think that's the the evidentiary
standard you know in physics is a very
different one you know we talk about
contravent
confidence intervals and you know five
sigma seven sigma
you know for for evidence you know for
extravagant claims although i always
think
you know the statement that
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence i don't know if
you ever reach into your when you're
arguing in front of the supreme court
i'm going to reach into my extraordinary
evidence bag now but you're right and
actually i think it's one of the reasons
i'm against the early voting
actually for exactly the reason that you
outlined you know something could happen
between you know uh october 3rd and
november 3rd like something he could
have done something or the opponents
could have done something
but i know you only have a few more
minutes i can't resist asking this from
a pure risk management standpoint you
know
you might think all i do is look through
telescopes all day but most of my days
thinking about risks like if that
concrete doesn't get up to our telescope
mount pad
by 3 p.m that you know on in uh next
thursday the telescope's not going to
work and we're not going to have diesel
fuel
blah blah you know so i'm thinking about
quotidian things much more than
most people assume when they hear the
august title of astronomer
but uh but actually a lot of what is
risk management and i'm i want to ask
you completely apolitically the show is
apolitical i always say there are no
democratic constellations
there's no republican asteroids out
there some i claim they're
you know donald j trump was a republican
asteroid but from a pure risk management
standpoint
no partisanship whatsoever is it smart
for the democrats to do let's say they
are
successful let's do a gdunkan experiment
let's say
democrats there's some evidence and the
republicans come through and they vote
and they can
they impeach him wouldn't that in some
sense from a very broad perspective be
very risky for democrats
in that they'll remove him from the
possibility and we didn't even get a
chance to talk about
like what the constitution doesn't talk
about term limits and obviously
you know people serve more than two
terms you know uh in our past history so
ignoring that no it does there is a
provision that limits president's
two terms although this guy i think if
he had gotten away with what he tried to
do
in 2020 and i can't avoid being somewhat
political about this i doubt that he
would have been
willing to leave after 2020 you know
after serving two terms
he would have yeah okay so either there
was in there i'm saying in the original
framing of the constitution
people yeah but um but ignoring that so
in the constitutional originalism
but just talking about from a risk
management standpoint isn't the best
thing that this guy comes back and runs
again
from the perspective of democrats you
know would be it would be enjoying
the fracturing of the republican party
i'm just speaking before
i'm not i don't take sides i'm a
political atheist yeah so you know i
thought that
that one of the house managers uh ted
liu made a very
powerful point um powerful partly
because he left it
with something that that the listener
had to think about he said
you know i'm not afraid that donald
trump will return
and win re-election he was pretty
confident
that the guy is so tired that he
wouldn't win
i'm afraid that he would return and lose
and if he returned and lost
we now know what he's capable of doing
in terms of
upsetting the ordinary rules of the game
i mean the ordinary rules the framers
were worried about
charismatic demagogues who would raise
private armies
mobs of people well armed to basically
rip apart the delicate framework that is
designed to hold together this set of
contradictions
and if he runs again and loses
and if his private army by then has
grown and become all the more angry
god knows what would happen this time it
really looks like he came
awfully close to killing having this mob
kill the vice president and the speaker
of the house
the entire line of succession then what
would he have done he surely would have
declared martial law
he would have said we now are in a state
of emergency a state of exception
a black hole is as it were in the
constitution
that could still happen so you know
whether you're a democrat or a
republican
in the risk assessment the risk that
that will happen
is one that we need to worry about
that's one of the arguments for
convicting and disqualifying him
but it's also an argument even if it
ends up that
we don't have the votes or they don't
have the votes to be a political even if
it turns out the democrats don't have
the votes
to convict and disqualify him
think of the downside of not having put
him on trial
it's true that he will claim some kind
of vindication that he is acquitted
but if he wasn't even put on trial for
essentially
enacting the framers worst nightmare
and coming very close to ripping apart
this delicate experiment in democracy
what would that say to the next tyrant
and the next
i mean i think that the destruction of
the republic
is a fairly existential singularity
that ought to be avoided in an
assessment of risks
absolutely and i know you you only have
a few minutes you've been so gracious
with your time
if you'll indulge me in some more
forbearance i i have to ask you a
question that i ask all my guests when
they come on the no uh
on the into the impossible podcast with
brian keating and that uh involves
um you know dealing with dealing with
quote unquote enemies
and and and how you um first of all why
do you
why are you so controversial i see you
as a person
um who's got extremely strong opinions
obviously very
very studied in history in the mastery
of your field
in the mastery of other fields or the
interest in curiosity which is what we
study at the arthur c clarke center for
human imagination
what is it about your positions that
make you controversial i've seen you
criticize your fellow traveler yeah
chuck schumer uh and and it seems
absolute in that sense that you're
guided by this compass which will get to
my question but
why do you think you're controversial
what is controversial about about
the positions i think honestly i'm
controversial because
i say what i believe and what i believe
is often very unpopular not always
but when i mean barack obama is somebody
i
trust admire he was my student my
research assistant
i'm very much in favor of taking
dramatic steps to deal with climate
change but he had a
clean air plan that i thought violated
the constitution
i wasn't happy about that i thought it
it
not in some fundamental way but because
it exceeded the
power that congress had delegated the
president and i said so and i
you know i had some success in
litigation
and barack wasn't all that happy about
it uh
more often i'm controversial because i
criticized
right-wing positions when i testified
against robert bork
when he was nominated to the court a lot
of people who i
otherwise were sort of friendly with
people like alan simpson and orrin hatch
senator said
larry you shouldn't have done that we
would have loved the court
with both you and robert work on it but
now you have basically poisoned the
water
we're never going to let you get on the
court and
sure enough that's the way it happened
but i'm actually very glad about the
trajectory i've had
i don't mind the controversy because
i've had a hell of a time
and i've had wonderful students and
they've done wonderful things
not all my students are all that
wonderful ted cruz was one of them i'm
not so proud of him but jamie rask and
i'm very proud of
uh but i'm controversial because i i
don't hesitate to speak my mind
yeah and that's that really brings me to
my final question which is
um revolves around this concept that in
judaism is known as an ethical will
zava ah and in um and alfred nobel
actually enacted this in
in the creation of the nobel prize which
was won by your student
uh barack obama of course and that was
that the nobel prize had to go not only
for physicists and chemists etc
uh but who made great discoveries but
those discoveries had to be for the
greater benefit
of all mankind they called it nowadays
they say human kindness
right yeah but but i want to ask you
when you reach the biblical
age of 120 years old um what kinds of
uh zava ah what kind of ethical will do
you want to convey that conveys not your
material goods but but as alfred
did his his his wisdom his teaching his
desire
to continue the future his biological
heirs but also his ideological errors
well first of all my hebrew isn't very
good after my bar mitzvah i didn't
continue with it so i wouldn't have
known how to phrase
that ethical will i suppose
my ethical compass or my moral compass
would be
to remember that you never have anything
except what you've given away
that what you have given what you've
contributed
is all you have
that's uh that is a very beautiful place
to end and uh i do want to thank you for
being so generous with your time larry
you're incredibly busy we'll tune in to
you on tv please i hope i can get you
back to ask you
how to unify quantum electrodynamics
with the weak force
i know that's that's your hobby on the
weekend so no but i would love to have
you back on if you're willing
i'd love it i'd love it thank you for
having me thank you
thank you so much bye